[Music]
this week on booknotes our guest is
robert wright senior editor at the new
republic
he joins us to discuss his recent book
the moral animal why we are the way we
are
[Music]
robert wright in the back of your book
you credit your brother mike for fueling
your fascination with this book and the
subject in ways he doesn't even know
about what are you talking about there
uh
well he was just an unusually moral guy
i would say i mean an unusually selfless
person and uh
kind of and i
a model member of our species i guess i
i would say and and a lot of the the
book is about uh
how is it that that animals that evolved
through natural selection this kind of
ruthless process uh as we apparently did
how is it that that they can be moral in
the first place that they can behave uh
selflessly and and be decent people
where's your brother he's in albuquerque
he lives in albuquerque now
uh what's the difference in age
he's uh five years older than i am so he
was a role model uh as as older siblings
often are and and so he's he's
responsible for i guess much of my
character for better or worse did you
grow up in albuquerque no no my father
was in the army um and both my parents
are from west texas rural west texas but
i grew up kind of all over the country
when you use the word moral what do you
mean
i guess uh
i mean
well then i would say the most moral
behavior
is behavior that is truly
self-sacrificial when people
really
really do something for other people
that does not
uh
accrue to their benefit in any way
we are a lot of the things that that we
do
that we call moral are are in round
about ways self-interested and there's
nothing wrong with that if you have a
friend and you do favors for the friend
and so on that's that's great and in
fact natural selection designed us to
have the impulses of gratitude and
affinity that govern these kinds of
relationships and they're good good for
the species and they're fine but i would
say the most moral behavior uh is is the
kind that is not in your self-interest
in in any sense i in the book i talk a
little about darwin because he was such
a a famously decent person and i show
some cases where he did he did that sort
of thing he he uh crusaded on behalf of
uh for example on behalf of the welfare
of animals even in in ways that didn't
didn't help him at all he was just he
just had a very acute conscience
and i look at the question of
why the conscience evolved in the first
place
and how it is it is such a flexible
mental mechanism
that we can
use it in a way more morally than it was
really designed to be used do truly
selfless things when did you come to the
new republic
uh in 1988 i i came uh
and uh i was writing editorials at that
point and then i've done a variety of
things since then i took a leave of
absence to write this book so i was gone
for two years what was the purpose of
the book
well there
it's about this field of evolutionary
psychology which uh
is i think a
a genuinely major intellectual
development and and and they're also
parallel things happening in other
social sciences especially anthropology
um
it's grounded in kind of a new way of
understanding the evolution of human
nature um and i'm personally convinced
that that this is the wave of the future
that this this this world view has so
much uh scientific merit that it's here
to stay
so i wanted to first of all lay it out
for people and help them understand it
um because i think it's going to be a
politically important a philosophically
important world view
um how will it be politically important
well
first of all darwinism
uh
has long had political ramifications uh
the stereotype is that the ramifications
are inherently conservative because
around the the turn of the century
what was called social darwinism
consisted of for example justifying the
oppression of the downtrodden on grounds
that this was in some way natural and
part of some divine natural plan so
historically um darwinism has been
has been used i would say misused
in the service pretty pretty exclusively
of right-wing
causes so so first of all i wanted to
look at this modern darwinian paradigm
evolutionary psychology and see if
that's really some kind of inherent
tendency if it has to help only the
right wing and i i try to show that it
that it doesn't um
for example it's not some kind of uh
crude form of genetic determinism which
says that the bad parts of society are
irremediably bad um in fact evolutionary
psychology pays a lot of attention to
the importance of early environment and
of cultural forces and so on so that's
just a misconception i wanted to dispel
about darwinism
where did you start getting interested
in all this
um
i've been interested in psychology and
human behavior all my life and i
actually think it has to do with having
moved around a lot because my father was
in the army because
uh
i noticed that every people everywhere
are basically the same and and i lived
in a lot of
quite varied environments in san
francisco i lived in schools that were
predominantly asian for example i went
to school in texas in virginia where
where in texas
well i lived in the various texas cities
but i went to school in el paso and
which school in san antonio and a year
of college in fort worth
i went to like five different elementary
schools or
something like that and
um
i guess i did kind of unconsciously
start to think about human nature i mean
what is it that all of these people have
in common it's a whole lot people
everywhere basically the same and that's
really the premise of evolutionary
psychology and and
here we come to another misconception
about darwinism that that all people who
are interested in a darwinian view of
human behavior
are arguing
that
differences in behavior between
different groups cultural groups or
ethnic groups are grounded in genetic
differences between those groups and
that that's not what evolutionary
psychology is about it's about the idea
that there is a universal human nature
and that that people's minds
everywhere on this planet are
fundamentally the same
before we go any farther you are at the
new republic and the new republic was
involved in the controversy over the
bell curve and charles murray and he's
done this program where do you stand on
the murray book well i wrote a column
about this a trb about this to to to try
to clear this up trb column trb column
which i guess yeah not everyone knows
it's a column that appears at the front
of the magazine and i write it every
other week
and
well first of all i i repeated this
point
that uh
evolutionary psychology that that all
the things people may be hearing about
new evolutionary views of behavior or or
the genetic basis of behavior do not at
all imply
murray's view of the world which is that
different ethnic groups are different
for
for reasons of different genes
um and then i also tried to
to show that uh
one of the concepts central to his book
uh it's technically called heritability
um
is much misunderstood
and a high number for heritability
doesn't mean what you probably think it
means i mean he he he notes that uh that
iq
for example is is by most studies around
.5 or 0.4 or 0.6 heritable what does
that mean
not at all what people think i mean it
doesn't
it doesn't mean
that you cannot uh
massively change iq
through
uh
through early educational influence the
heritability of a trait says nothing
about how easy or hard it is to change
you're talking about heredity yeah
passing down through explain what
heredity is well heredity is is that the
transmission of traits uh through the
genes and and this is what uh you know
darwin's theory is is very much
uh about of course because the whole
theory is
that
those genetically based
traits uh
which in a sense are conducive to
getting the underlying genes into the
next generation are that are the traits
that are with us today for example
hunger okay if you imagine two ancestors
one that had a gene inclining him to eat
food
you know he was hungry another that
didn't have that sensation well the one
without the sensation his genes are
going nowhere because he'll die before
he can reproduce okay so that's why the
sensation of hunger is with us today
genes for hunger got through the what's
a gene
a gene is a it's a unit
of hereditary information and most of
the traits
you
you know you think about including
mental traits involve a whole lot of
genes there are very few kind of single
gene
traits so anything that i talk about in
the book like
the conscience or sensations of
guilt or
lust or romantic love
or or this phenomenon of varying
self-esteem all these things are part of
our evolutionary heritage but none of
them none of them is based on only one
gene they're all very complex traits you
say you lived in texas you live in san
francisco you live in virginia
um
i i lived yeah i lived on on fort monroe
i went to fifth grade in fort monroe
virginia
that's located
down here
near the chesapeake virginia beach uh
right on the other side of the bay from
virginia what what service was your
father in he was in the army is he still
alive no he's not eating
about your mother uh she's alive living
in northern california where where two
of my sisters live with all their kids
total number of kids in the family
five kids in my family
and i guess my mother now has somewhere
around 14 or 15 grandkids so i guess her
genes are doing well and you're married
i am i have two very young daughters
where are you in the uh
with your siblings how the older younger
where do you fit i'm uh the fourth
youngest uh but there was a there was a
five-year gap between me and the next
oldest so
i guess i got a little more pampered
than a lot of
younger offspring how many how much
education do you have i i have a
bachelor's degree from princeton and
that's it
some place in this book and this is
jumping out of context i think you write
one of the theories
is that a the oldest son will not be a
revolutionary or a radical
yeah that's actually draws on on the
work of uh uh frank sulloway who has a
book coming out on that on that subject
um
he found
that uh later born children as opposed
to firstborn are much more likely to uh
to support scientific revolutions
like the darwinian revolution or even
political revolutions and uh
that's interesting because it shows it's
one of the many many cases where
systematic differences between in
behavior exist
not because of differences in genes
there's no there's no systematic
difference between the genes that a
firstborn child gets in later born
children get the genes are randomly
passed out to these kids but there is
this pattern that later born kids are
are much more radical or much more open
to radical ideas and and
um and frank thinks about this in a kind
of evolutionary way who is he frank
soloway is a uh he's a he's at mit now
he wrote a book called uh freud
biologist of the mind
um
some years back um and he's something of
a general story he's an historian of
science for an academic watching this
who has a phd in psychology what would
you say to them when they would say well
he can't possibly know what he's talking
about he doesn't have a phd in
psychology
um
they may be right i you know i it's
possible it's possible that i'm wrong
about all this stuff but uh
all i would ask is that they read the
book first because this is not this is
not a something that you could this
whole world view this whole evolutionary
psychology this kind of new darwinian
paradigm it's not something you can
prove to people by having them look
through a microscope it's not that kind
of science and in fact the human
behavioral sciences have never been that
kind of science it
it's a science in which uh evidence
comes from a variety of sources and uh
you have to kind of go through and weigh
the evidence but i submit that when you
look at the evidence from anthropology
in other words things that are true in
cultures around the world
look at the evidence from other species
including those that are most closely
related to us uh look at darwinian
theory itself and really understand the
theory of natural selection and what it
predicts i think people will find the
world view really persuasive how would
the world be different if charles darwin
never lived
well it depends somewhat on your your
view of scientific history and whether
you have a kind of great man or great
thinker view of science history or
whether you
you view the truth as something that's
kind of out there that science is
converging upon
and i take the latter view and in fact
there was even before darwin published
there was another naturalist who arrived
at the same theory the theory of natural
selection
and uh for a while it looked like he
might get all the credit and in fact uh
this
you know i oddly enough the person he
chose to mail his theory to was charles
darwin who had not yet announced his
theory of natural selection darwin's
darwin's sitting there in his study and
he's been working on this this great
book for years and years and hasn't told
the world about his theory and all of a
sudden he gets this letter in the mail
with this outline of his theory
and this was um a great great crisis in
his life and and in the book i mean in
general i used darwin as kind of a
narrative device and i i go through
how he handled this this crisis
and the general perception has always
been that he was just inordinately
decent and generous in the way he
handled this this threat to his own
status
i try to show that that actually whether
whether
whether consciously or not he was very
cunning and ultimately self-serving in
this case uh
he he uh basically a
a coalition of male primates you might
say they were his friends um
he kind of turned the matter over to
them how he said how should i handle
this they were very influential men of
science he he subtly steered them toward
you know the way they ended up handling
it and they handled it in a way that
basically preserved his his social
status preserved his preeminence as
evolutionary theorist
uh
without
uh incurring any kind of reputation for
having done anything unethical which
itself would have been a threat to his
status especially in victorian society
when did charles darwin live
he was born in 1809 uh the great book
the origin of species was
published in 1859 although he had
discovered the theory
around 20 years early earlier and he
went that long without telling people
about it and he was
he was a very kind of intellectually
insecure person in some respects i mean
he was very worried about being proven
wrong and of course this was a
thoroughly heretical
idea evolution in those days
um where did he live he lived in england
uh he was born to a kind of upper middle
class
family in rural england
and a very uh
a fairly prominent family in fact his
grandfather erasmus
uh had actually uh had a theory of
evolution it was just the wrong theory
and and darwin had read that
uh as a as as a child and and i think
actually its influence on him
was greater than he ever admitted or
probably consciously
knew i mean one one of the things i talk
about in the book is how
we all are are probably designed by
natural selection
to
convince people often that we deserve
more credit for things than we actually
deserve and that in the service of that
goal we are inclined to even deceive
ourselves
about it and you and you can go back and
find in in erasmus work
uh at least one sentence that really
anticipates the basic idea of natural
selection um
and uh darwin never
never called attention to that passage
and in fact he he felt that that that
he contended his grandfather was totally
on the wrong track how long did he live
he lived until i guess he was 73
i
died in 1882 i think
he was married for how long
he got married when he was uh
around 30 and he was married the whole
the whole rest of his life his men
commonly were in victorian england and i
look i look at his marriage in the book
and i look at marriage in in general in
victorian england in the book because
the victorians were so successful at
preserving marriage it's something we're
not all that good at and
one thing evolutionary psychology tells
you is that indeed it will be a
challenge to preserve monogamous
marriages because in some ways
that goal runs against human nature and
and in fact i think although i'm not
advocating a wholesale return to
victorian morality uh
i do think that once you understand
human nature through modern uh darwinian
lights it's a lot harder to laugh at
victorian morality to the various you
know repressive aspects of it because
i think that sort of moral firepower or
something like it may in fact be needed
to to preserve the institution of
monogamy in a modern society how many
children did he have
he had ten
uh and seven survived to
adulthood uh he he lost three children
at various
at various ages and um and actually one
of the more
kind of cynical
darwinian theories about human nature
and there's really no shortage of them
there are a few of them um
is that
the
the amount of affection that parents
feel for different children if you want
to see how parents favor different
children
it depends heavily on the various
characteristics that the children have
and
ranging from sex to age to various other
things um and it has to do with you know
which kinds of children during human
evolution would have been
the best reproductive assets in other
words what kinds of children
in what kinds of circumstances would
have been most likely to have the most
kids and the idea is that parents are
unconsciously motivated without thinking
about it
to treat different children accordingly
and
um
in the book i show that you know there's
a there's a there's a darwinian theory
about why parents feel
grief different tend to feel different
amounts of grief over the death of
different children of differing ages and
i show that at least darwin's behavior
certainly complies with the theory
where was he educated
um
he was he was educated at cambridge
uh cambridge university cambridge
university in england he uh
got a lot of his important education
aboard the uh the beagle the the ship
that he sailed on after uh after he got
out of cambridge it went around the
world and he collected animals from all
kinds of places um most famously the
galapagos islands um
and he didn't really understand
their importance until he got back i
mean he was not an evolutionist when he
got when he got back from
from the journey but but in a very short
period of time he put it all together
let me ask you again what does it mean
to be an evolutionist
uh strictly speaking
it just means that you believe in in
evolution i guess so there were there
were absolutely
uh
you believe that all animals
evolved that that
they
uh including us uh so you can be an
evolutionist without believing in
natural selection which is the darwin's
theory and the one that that people
accept today so they were evolutionists
before
there was darwin but there weren't
darwinians before there was darwin to be
a darwinian means that you believe in
the theory of natural selection what
does that mean
that theory says that um
the the
uh the basic dynamic of evolution the
thing that produces evolution is that
so there there are these things called
genes although darwin himself didn't
know about genes can you see genes
well whether you if you live with a you
know um in principle yes i mean it it it
it takes a very strong microscope to see
even dna it's even a long strand of dna
but it's
it's uh it's it's there it's physical
stuff um
and
although darwin didn't put the theory in
terms of genes uh
the idea is that
those hereditary traits
which are conducive
as he put it to survival and
reproduction
um are the traits that will of course
get passed on through the generations by
definition
uh
the we've since found out that it's a
little more complicated than survival
and reproduction for example if you do
something for a
sibling
uh
since siblings contain a lot more of
your genes than the average person in
the population that may actually help
your genes get into the next generation
and that explains why siblings in fact
love one another i mean i have to ask
you about politics because you know
basically this is a network that talks
about politics and you write for a
political magazine
and you do mention politics in here
um
how can you apply what's in this book
to the future discussion of
conservatives and liberals in other
words who's going to like this book the
most and who's going to dislike this
book the most
i would like to think that no political
group uh
will feel
unequivocally about it i mean there's
probably some good news and some bad
news
for for all sides of of
various parts of the political spectrum
um there are some parts that some will
like in some parts that that uh that
others will like what's a conservative
gonna like
um
well a conservative a conservative may
at first like to hear
that uh humans are
designed uh to live in social
hierarchies
uh that is that you know we're a
hierarchical uh species and we're all
into
to some extent social climbers by nature
in ways that we don't even understand
but
you know
on the other hand on closer examination
it it doesn't mean what some
conservatives uh might think it doesn't
mean uh for example that's that that
some people are born to to be
uh to be downtrodden to be you know at
the lower part of the social hierarchy
and and selflessly serve the public good
or anything like that in fact what what
the theory says is that we are all
equipped with a fairly intense desire to
be uh high status people and um
circumstance may play a large role in in
who actually gets to be high status
people uh
and
and so liberal may point out that by
altering the the
the circumstance
you can you can you can change things
uh like like social stratification for
example
um are you a liberal or a conservative
i'm i i guess i've always said i was
more liberal and conservative although
all uh
in general political labels are just
just a lot less clear than i think they
were at one point i i would call myself
a neo-liberal i guess
why did either marty parrots or andrew
sullivan hire you to be what every other
week in trb
uh
yeah um
that's a good question the uh the uh i
think partly when
you know when mike kinsley gave up the
job uh
it may not have taken them long to
realize that it would be hard to find
any single person who could fill his
shoes um that may be part of the answer
i alternate with uh with mickey cows um
and i guess maybe they thought that you
know i have
a certain familiarity with scientific
issues technological issues um
and
i uh
mickey is is probably better versed in
in sheer politics and
public policy so maybe they thought that
would be an interesting um
an interesting package i i write i write
about things without talking about
science and technology but
i do i've you know i very my last column
was about family values from the from
the point of view of evolutionary
psychology so that's
that's an example of something that that
you know probably the average washington
columnist would not have written it was
it was scientifically informed
when you sit down to write a book like
this and you have things like the new
darwinian paradigm
that that phrase
did it worry you that you might have
people say uh you know i don't even know
what he's talking about what's a
paradigm and what's the new darwinian
paradigm
uh
yeah
uh it's a it's
a you know chronic fear of authors is
people putting the book down on page two
and and uh
and
uh
that i guess that's why i i tried to get
fairly early in the book into into
darwin's life and use him throughout as
a kind of vehicle here's a there's a
typical person in fact supposedly a much
nicer than average person really
um how do we understand his mind and his
behavior
through
the lens of modern darwinism i mean and
these are ideas that he himself didn't
really have access to they're extensions
of his own theory
but uh
but they're a lot of the extensions have
taken terms that he himself did not
anticipate although i'm sure he would
embrace them let me though go to the
name darwin i mean almost anybody today
would know that name
um
why do you think that his name has
survived all these years
uh because he was so right and and he
because it gets back to the fact that as
i was saying he's very he was very
intellectually insecure and he spent all
these years before he unveiled the
theory making sure he had it basically
right and gathering all of this evidence
and and looking at things that seem to
contradict the theory uh
for example why would why would peacocks
be so colorful how does that help
survival in reproduction i mean it's
these these huge colorful tales just
seem a daily encumbrance if anything
and he answered that question correctly
the answer is stood up for a century um
why
if indeed traits conducive to
uh
to getting themselves into next
generation the next generation are the
traits that natural selection favors why
are there casts of ants that are sterile
that don't have offspring
and he answered that question in a way
that is withstood the test of time in
fact
people didn't really understand the
genius of his answer until the last 20
or 30 years when a biologist named
william hamilton came along and
reformulated it in the modern language
of genes in a much more clear way so
darwin
although alfred wallace had come up with
a theory
by the time darwin published
darwin is truly the guy who deserves the
credit by any reasonable record let me
read this paragraph and this is just in
the middle of the book it says we can
now roughly sketch a charles darwin plan
for marital bliss
have a chaste
courtship marry an angel
move to the country not long after the
wedding
have tons of kids and sink into a deeply
debilitating illness
a heartfelt commitment to your work
probably helps too especially when the
work doesn't entail business trips what
is that all about uh
well
it is about i mean the backdrop of it is
that lifelong monogamy
is not an easy is not an easy goal to
reach for a society but is that him by
the way that is him
i mean and and i and for example
certainly the fact that he was he was
sick his whole life uh
deprived him of the energy might have
otherwise used the philander i don't
know so that's you know it's true what
was his illness
it's never really been satisfactorily
diagnosed and it wasn't at the time but
it was it was a real thing with real
physical symptoms he was and and various
physical symptoms um but um
it kept him you know confined to his
home and any he lived in rural england
and that further cut down the chances of
falling in love with someone else but as
as for the part about um
having a chase courtship
you know i'm not necessarily
recommending that
for for everyone but but i do argue in
the book that um
uh
that there are various parts of
victorian morality that in retrospect
were conducive to
successful monogamous monogamous
marriage
in ways that are hard to understand
without evolutionary psychology
and
um
a chase courtship isn't is an example of
that i don't expect to see the return of
the chase courtship as as the you know
as the norm in america but um
i do argue for example uh uh
that in in many ways an atmosphere of
sexual looseness um
has hurt
women in our society uh in ways that
they'll understand better if they
understand the way the the mind evolved
and the way the male and the female
minds evolved i mean they're these two
minds are in some ways different
according to modern darwinism if charles
darwin was alive today what would be his
politics
well he was certainly a liberal by the
standards of his day of of course the
people that we you know 19th century
liberals
who were at the left toward the left end
of their political spectrum some of the
beliefs they held may seem you know
centrist or or even to the right
by our standards but he was definitely
at the left end of his uh
political spectrum
and he was
a very his politics were very humane i
would say he was an ardent opponent of
slavery
as i said he was something of an animal
welfare crusader
he was very concerned about the plight
of the of the downtrodden in society how
did you go to learn about him
i uh
i didn't initially plan to because when
i started the book four years ago i
didn't
i didn't have this idea that he would be
such a central part of it
um
in fact i remember going to a bookstore
right when i started writing the book
and seeing a used bookstore and seeing
his autobiography on the shelf and
thinking well i need that and you know i
decided no and i walked off and now it's
kind of hard to imagine that i ever
thought that
but uh i read his autobiography i read
the number of biographies
and then uh fortunately his
correspondence up through around 1860 up
through the
publication of the origin is now
very nicely collected by cambridge
university press so i
i got all
of those things to refer to
i started the book four years ago
what was the hardest part of writing it
gathering it and writing it um
that's a good question the uh
just doing it i mean just uh
just every day actually setting about to
write it it was easy to to explore the
ideas learning about darwin was a lot of
fun and about the field was a lot of fun
but finally forcing myself to sit down
and write um
because it's hard to feel you really
have mastered
this kind of stuff well enough to write
and and you have to kind of start
writing and then find out that you're
right you had not mastered it but at
least
once you
you've tried to write it you understand
exactly what you're lacking you go back
and learn more let me take a big leap
having
let's say read your book or having the
background of knowledge you have
does it help you at all understand bill
clinton
or newt gingrich
is there anything in here that would you
know all the discussion we have now
about family values about morals and
yeah all the uh scandals and and what's
well it helps me a lot i mean
uh
newt gingrich is a man who's divorced he
he divorced his wife and married a
younger woman
bill clinton is a person who's been
accused of fooling around on the side a
certain amount
if you look at the evolutionary origin
of politics
you know one vivid way to do that is to
go look at a chimpanzee society as crude
as this may sound they're our nearest uh
or nearest primate relatives and uh they
are political species they they males
form uh coalitions
that that seek power and status and upon
attaining power and status the males try
to translate that into sexual access to
females and they often succeed
um
and i'm afraid for better or worse that
that is a parallel
that says a lot about our species in
fact if you look at the whole history of
politics
going back in into pre-history um
there's a lot of evidence that that men
throughout history have
uh ardently sought power or status and
tried to convert it
into
uh into access to women uh
in most societies most societies have
really been polygamous and so and the
powerful or high status men had more
than one
uh wife uh in a monogamous society
uh a powerful man has to kind of
get rid of the first wife to acquire the
second one that's what newt gingrich did
now
i'm not saying any of this is good you
know you
once you look at human nature from a
modern evolutionary point of view it's
very clear that not everything that's
natural is good
um and i'm not saying that this is
unchangeable but
uh
as i recently pointed out in in in a
column um
if
if newt gingrich is really serious about
family values
uh
he might might want to think about the
fact that uh
it's a it's an uphill struggle against
human nature to sustain monogamous
marriage and
those societies that have succeeded like
victorian england
have typically done it
by stigmatizing men who left their
families so
if he wants to if he wants a society
with family values it's a society in
which someone like him would not be able
to hold elective office and i mean that
pretty seriously it's if you if you look
back at victorian england which was very
successful at sustaining monogamy that's
the kind of price men paid if they
wanted to leave their families
um
the other
as long as we're on the subject of
hypocrisy i would say that that that's a
very human trait none of us are exempt
from it um
and uh
one of the ideas that emerges from
evolutionary psychology is that we're
all designed to kind of
first of all convince the world that
we're moral and decent people and in the
process that sometimes means convincing
ourselves so really deceiving ourselves
about our own moral record and uh
i think that's in a way what newt
gingrich has done i don't think he's the
only one he
he is certainly i think one of the most
vivid
and dramatic examples of that by my
lights but uh it's a tendency that's
that's in all of us
what about bill clinton what do you see
there well the the idea that that a male
upon attaining power would try to
convert it into sexual access to young
women of fertile age
you know even though even though in the
modern world you use contraception and
so
this doesn't get translated into into
offspring
still if you ask why does the impulse of
lust exist in a man and why does it seem
to be heightened by his attainment of
social status or power you know the
answer lies in evolution is because
during our evolutionary past before
there was contraception
status
could be was translated into actual
offspring into the transmission uh
of genes so um
it's uh
a lot of i must say i mean all of
washington kind of comes into sharper
focus
from this from this point of view i
think i mean there's a there's a little
section of the book on on
chimpanzee politics which is a reference
to a very good book called chimpanzee
politics which studied this at length
but you really
even if you you know don't get immersed
into evolutionary theory and don't
you know and just just look at a
description of how a chimpanzee society
is structured
uh the parallels are striking and eerie
in in the way uh males behave in the two
species give us some other parallels
well in this town you're talking about
now yeah
uh the uh
um
a certain ideological flexibility in the
service of pursuing
power or status
one thing they notice about male and
female chimps is that males are much
more opportunistic in their allegiances
a female chimps friends often stay very
stable from year to year throughout a
whole life and their allegiance uh is is
is more enduring
a male a male chimp uh
in the interest of of of elevating his
own social status will very well will
easily
shift coalitions in other words stab a
former coalition member um in the back
now it's been noted in our species by
people including some people who call
themselves different feminists and are
talking about differences between men or
women men and women it's been noted
that
males are particularly males of our
species seem to be particularly
flexible strategically in much the same
way
um in terms of shifting alliances with
different males
uh but also in terms of ideology i mean
if you if you go through
uh and you're seeing this happen right
now in washington because
the perception whether it's valid or not
is that people on the left are going to
have to move to the center
uh
to
to hang on to power
and
you know bill clinton is making some
noises about being quite willing to do
that and this is
this is behavior that
both men and women are capable of i
would say it's more characteristically
male though and in fact i i
i predict that you'll you'll you'll
you'll see hillary having more trouble
doing this than bill
what about yourself uh after studying
all this
and writing this book
do you find yourself completely
comprehending every move you make
in your own relationship with your own
wife and the kids and it's it's a hard
world view to get away from once you
really absorb it it can
it can definitely change your view of
life of of your own behavior your own
motivation and of the motivation of
other people and
since one of the themes of evolutionary
psychology is that
a lot of our motivation is unconscious
and we don't understand it's it's it's
it's nature um
you know once you start thinking this
way you you become kind of suspicious of
your own behavior probably appropriately
so um
so it's it it can in some ways be it's
an enlightening view but i think it can
in some ways be an uncomfortable uh
world view to to carry
uh uh to live with um and
you know i one thing i say in the book
is that i think that may be good in in
some ways i mean i think um
i guess uh
martin luther said that a saint is a
person who understands that everything
he does is is egotistical well
that would be an exact that would be an
overly cynical view even by modern
darwinian lights there are there are we
sometimes behave with true altruism but
um
i do think it's true that this worldview
leads you to be more suspicious of
yourself in somewhat this way
and i think that's a healthy that's a
healthy thing i mean for for people it's
a healthy thing for society if people
have
very active consciences and i think
i think this worldview can make your
conscience more active page 219 you
write this the culture
of personality does have a shallow feel
and it's easy to get nostalgic for the
days when sure glibness got a person
less far in life
but that doesn't mean the reign of
character was an era of pure integrity
unsullied by self-interest
what are you getting at
i'm talking there about victorian
morality and again charles darwin's own
conscience and uh
how well suited it was to his culture
it was an acute conscience he felt a
strong sense of obligation
to other people um
you say he would wake up in the middle
of the night
and worry about whether he owed somebody
a letter yeah or what yeah someone he
didn't even know uh or whether he had
offended some friend in some with some
casual remark that day that's the kind
of person he was
um and more people were like that
probably then than now because it was a
culture that encouraged
uh having an acute conscience let me
stop you about the victorian era what
what was it can you explain what life
would have been like if we had been
living in the victorian era um and when
was it
there would be uh
it was
it's generally it's generally considered
to be kind of from around the uh
the the around 1830 through toward you
know until 1870 1880 different people
marked the era differently
but uh
it's among other things an age of
extreme conscientiousness was it
worldwide
uh no but it but it had a strong
influence on american culture i'd say
and in fact a lot of you know you could
say that that that uh
early 20th century america even up
through the 50s was in some ways had
strong traces of victorianism
in it um
name three or four differences then and
now
well divorce was a scandal
uh in in in uh you know certainly in the
early
1950s for almost all strata of american
society
uh you didn't just hear well they're
getting a divorce oh what else is new
today you say half the people yeah half
marriages end in divorce yeah
uh is that worldwide or is that just the
united states
um
it's not worldwide but but it's not uh
it's not
unlike other other western societies not
unlike england's rate what are the other
differences
um
being uh being caught for example lying
was a more it was a more serious thing
than i mean it was
it was uh it was the reign of the
concept of character
as the basic way to judge a person as
opposed to personality there's a whole
separate literature on this about how
personality came to replace uh character
as the judge of a prayer but in
victorian days it was character it was
you know are you are you honest are you
a person of your word can you be trusted
um
and uh
you know do men treat women in ways that
are considered uh
you know decent and respectful
um
were there mistresses
there were there were mistresses they
were uh
it was
and then there was a lot of prostitution
in london as well
um and and in some ways
what uh
the deal kind of struck in victorian
england was well okay high status men
uh
may be allowed to fool around but first
of all they better not get caught they
better not talk about it it wasn't it
was it was an unseemly thing
but above all they better not leave
their families that that was the
unforgivable sin back to what you say
here the culture of personality
does have a shallow feel is this a
culture of personality in this town
in this town i would say in this country
certainly much more than was the case
earlier uh earlier this this century
um
yeah i think that's that's
much remarked upon and i think it's
absolutely uh it's absolutely true that
you know like just all kinds of scandals
people recover from
uh
in ways that they would not have uh
earlier whether uh
you know plagiarism or some sort of you
know and
let me go back to your in this context
go back to your new darwinian paradigm
state what it is again
it is and how new is it what's that what
how new is it the ideas
go back to the 1960s and 1970s when when
the the whole theory of natural
selection got kind of refined and
amended in important ways
the early applications were to non-human
animals and
early attempts to apply this this view
to humans to understand human behavior
of the human mind
were first of all not all that
sophisticated secondly were
uh were kind of drowned in a in a
barrage of politically motivated
criticism
um
so uh
and that kind of subsided and it kind of
went underground at least as far as the
application to humans goes and then
over the last 10 or 15 years uh a lot of
work was done in the social sciences and
psychology and other social sciences
and this new
kind of version emerged called the
evolutionary psychology
uh
but it's its origins go back i mean 1964
is a threshold when it became clear that
the theory of evolution explained why
siblings love one another
that
that involved a kind of theoretical
refinement really clarified people's
views of how
evolution works and then in the next 10
years or so
people started explaining just a whole
lot about human nature um
by by direct if subtle extensions of the
theory of natural selection why people
everywhere feel gratitude why people in
all cultures have friends
why men and women are different in a few
basic uh in a few basic ways
and and the the world view is just now i
would say crystallizing and and it
finally has
what i consider to be an overwhelming
amount of evidence
on it on its side but let me apply a
very basic uh
view to this a simple view somebody
reads this book the moral animal by
robert wright
and they buy off on your theory
what how will this help them better
understand where we're going
um
i think it'll help them understand just
how fundamental some of the problems we
face are
it will help them for example war it
will help them see how fundamental the
impulse is
to
um
identify
with your group of people and convince
yourself that you're morally superior
you're in the right
and it's the other side that has the
unjust grievance you have the just one
and i hope that when people understand
that they'll be a little suspicious of
their sense of self certainty in all
kinds of moral matters including the
kinds that that lead to wars
as i said i think i think this this
worldview helps people understand
the family values problem
uh in a way that they wouldn't have
before i think first of all it helps
them understand it is a genuine problem
when a lot of kids are growing up
without their biological fathers
that's a major major loss to society
because it's unlikely that a stepfather
is going to love them uh with nearly the
sort of devotion that a natural father
has and evolution explains why at the
same time it tells us that there's no
simple way out of
out of this family values miss i mean
it's it there will we you know we will
not solve the problem without sacrifice
without costs and
and we may uh
in some ways have to return to a
somewhat harsher uh morality to do it
who's lisa
lisa is my wife who uh gets gets uh top
billing in the acknowledgments and to
whom the book is devoted
she
helped me a lot with a book
what's her background
she is uh
she was an english teacher before she
met me
um
she uh and actually when when i met her
she was working on educational software
and she's
kind of an editor for for
for me although she had not done that
professionally uh previously you two
agree on this theory um she basically
subscribes to the overall world view i i
don't think she'll sign off on
everything in in the book um
and in fact she noted that during the
writing of the book and there are some
things that
that would be that would be in it that
that aren't because of her and i think
it's good that they aren't i mean she
enlightened me in some ways uh
as to
um especially
you know with some of the moralizing i
do and and
and uh some of the discussion uh some
extension of this to modern morality and
the implications for men as opposed to
women
you know she helped me understand uh
how women are
aggrieved in ways i might not have
understood and in how
uh some of these things might
might rub women the wrong way as i had
phrased them although it
does seem to have
to have rubbed at least a couple of
feminists the wrong way and in spite of
uh in spite of that but
um where'd you meet her
uh in new york when i write shortly
before i came to to the new republic you
left princeton in what year um 1979 i
graduated so 16 years ago uh yeah
great so and where did you go
uh i i first of all i declared myself uh
a writer what was your degree in uh the
degree was in in public and
international affairs the woodrow wilson
school it's it's interdisciplinary um
and and my first impulse was to say well
okay i'm a writer now i'll just kind of
wait for people to discover me or
something i guess i was going to be a
freelance writer um and uh
no way the world the world failed to
discover me surprisingly enough
so i finally got a job
at a small newspaper in new jersey that
no longer exists a small daily
um
and then i i went to work at the wilson
quarterly briefly a magazine here in
washington went to a magazine called the
sciences in new york that's put out by
the new york academy of sciences
kind of
wrote a book during that period and then
right after that
came to the new republic
is this your first book uh no the the uh
there was this book uh
called three scientists and their gods
which i wrote while i was uh at the
sciences
which had
uh
elements of this world view in it one of
the profiles in that book is of of uh
e.o wilson who wrote the book
sociobiology
which was one of the
earliest attempts to apply this to human
beings was much criticized
sometimes for good reasons it wasn't it
wasn't a very mature field at that point
but often for
surely political reasons
you spend a lot of time in the book
writing about
john stuart mill
who was he and uh what was his book on
liberty
uh
mill was a a liberal at least by the
standards of 19th century politics and a
reformer
um where do you live
he lived in england uh and
he
on liberty is often is often
taken
as uh
in some ways it was an argument that
uh
we should let people do
more or less whatever they want um
unless it it it hurts other people in
some fairly clear way i think
in truth mill was somewhat more morally
conservative that and than that in truth
in fact you you will find him saying
that divorce is okay if you don't have
kids you won't find him saying divorce
is okay if you do have kids
um
but
a lot of
a lot of aspects of his thought i mean
he lived when darwin lived darwin was a
fan of his they were they were
politically and ideologically allied
and just a lot of things in mill's
philosophy are good vehicles for looking
at the issues
that
that
evolutionary psychology poses for
example look at this question of
if something's natural is it good if we
have a natural impulse is it necessarily
a good impulse and there are certainly
parts of mill's thought that
not in on liberty but in other things
that i think are powerful arguments for
saying uh for saying no
and another man you write about is
samuel smiles and he has a book called
self-help who is he
right it was kind of the first that was
the first self-help book he and it was a
very that was a classically victorian
morally conservative book
and and he's
in that sense you might take as kind of
a polar opposite from mill because he
was bigger on self-discipline and
self-restraint
which the victorians in general were
were big on europe he was he from ribbon
he was he was in fact his book came out
the same year that darwin's book the
origin of species came out um
and and that's the year that mills on
liberty came out which is another reason
i used the three books uh i used as
reference points they make convenient
reference points but um
you know and and i try to show that
there was a certain amount of wisdom
given up the modern view of human nature
in
in samuel smiles
emphasis on on self-restraint and
self-discipline because we aren't
we are not you know naturally good
creatures i mean we're lucky to be
blessed with a lot of kind of moral
equipment you know compassion is is a
product of evolution and and the
conscience is and and so on and we have
the capacity to for tremendous sympathy
toward the downtrodden and everything
else
but uh
in some ways we deploy these sentiments
um more selectively than than would be
ideal morally probably after writing
this book and thinking about all this
have you changed your life in any way
uh
well
i guess i am more conscious for example
of trying to treat my kids equally
first of all in trying to make the
object of the game to make them happy
uh
as opposed to kind of converting them
into optimal reproductive vehicles which
is is probably in some sense what
parents are designed to try to turn
their kids into i mean uh darwin's
father for example was very hard on him
and he said you
you you'll be a disgrace to the family
you're worthless and and that led darwin
to work very hard not to be a disgrace
it made him very ambitious in subtle
ways
and it may well be the reason he became
famous as he did
but it caused him a huge amount of
psychic pain and he might have been
happier
if his father had been you know kind of
less bent on turning him into a high
status male
uh and and
so i guess i'd like to think that that
if i'm ever forced with choices like
this
um
between a child's happiness um
and and a child's you know social status
whatever whatever i'll i'd like to think
i'll opt for
happiness you show the audience what the
cover of the book looks like and by the
way
what's this graphic right here on
this
that's a an object of art that uh
that
the cover designer
uh at pantheon uh
marge anderson came up with and it's
very it's actually very ambiguous it's
kind of a rorschach test people see
different things in it i see in it
somebody who is
uh
who is
trying to um
kind of trying to to define
himself come to
come to terms with himself he's kind of
groping
uh to actually feel his own his own head
i mean as if you're trying to
to figure out what his mental essence is
um
and
he doesn't appear to be entirely happy
with the answers he's getting um the the
uh
um
and i'd say that's that's that's that's
that's true of evolutionary psychology i
mean there's some good news and there's
uh and there's some some bad news
robert wright is with the new republic
you can see his name on the trb column
and he's the author of this book the
moral animal thank you very much thank
you
[Music]
for a transcript of this book notes
program please send five dollars to
c-span transcripts in care of tape rider
incorporated post office box 885 lincoln